Freak bitches
for the social justice warrior types out there who might be listening.
It's like,
do you,
are you really willing to say that every single person who's accomplished
something as done that as a consequence of oppression,
that that's again what the Soviets claimed with regards to the to the successful
peasants in the 19,
in the just before the 19 twenties.
It's like,
well,
the peasants were in demand,
some painted.
They were serfs until about 30 years before that they were served.
They were basically slaves and some of them had clambered up to the point where
maybe they could have owned their hot and a cow and couldn't.
You don't employ someone while the Soviet claim was,
well,
that's all theft.
You got that all [inaudible],
you're an oppressor.
And so then the Soviet intellectuals went into the villages and just imagine how
this happened.
So imagine a village,
small town where everyone knows everybody and there's maybe 10,
20 people there who are moderately successful.
Okay?
And so you can imagine that those 20 people have like 100 enemies at the bottom
of the socioeconomic distribution.
Useless,
horrible.
People who are jealous and resentful about the fact that these people have been
successful.
Okay,
so now the intellectuals come in and say property is theft,
success is oppression,
and then they looked for the people in the village who are willing to move
against those 20 successful people.
Well those guys at the bottom,
those 100 resentful,
jealous,
murderous people at the bottom there just waiting for an opportunity to go kick
down some doors and that's exactly what they did in the 19 twenties.
And as I said,
they wiped out all their productive peasants and then 6 million Ukrainian starve
to death.
They had posters.
The Soviets produced posters in the 19 thirties that said,
essentially,
don't forget it's wrong to eat your children.
So whoa.
Yeah,
whoa.
There's nothing about the Soviet.
There's nothing that you can imagine that's horrible enough so that it matched
the reality of what happened in the Soviet Union between 19,
19 in 1959.
Uh,
I think also technology is just,
it's just trying to get us more and more addicted to it.
I was thinking of this the other day and I was flying back from Hawaii.
I was thinking of how many people I see stare at a phone at the airport,
at the fucking mall,
at a restaurant myself.
I'm staring at my own phone and I'm not immune to it.
We're all staring at fucking phones and I'm like,
if I was a pilgrim,
if you took,
you went back in a time machine,
you grabbed a pilgrim and dragged them to 2016 and he said,
what are you saying?
It be like,
oh my God,
they're all prisoners to the looking glass.
He'd been captured like slipped runners spell under a spell.
They stare at a fucking glass screen first thing in the morning.
They check their email to go to work.
They stare at a screen.
They look at their navigation system while they're fucking driving to work.
They get home,
they watch tv before they go to bed.
They check their email again.
They're just staring at fucking screens.
They're living their lives through screens.
I would think that looking glass,
it's captivated though.
I would think they were under the spell of glass,
like there was something about something bond.
They're not moving.
They're just sitting there in front of this fucking thing all day.
They're almost.
There's almost no movement.
Almost all the time you're in front of a screen.
You're just sitting there.
Yeah.
If you saw that and you had no idea what the fuck a television was or a phone,
you were just a person from another time period and he said,
what do you think's going on?
Like with these fucking people are under a spell.
They're clearly under a spell.
Like it's given them something.
Yeah,
but that's what a spell his fucking.
When the,
the,
the hypnotic dancer dances in front of you and then all of a sudden you don't
even know where you are anymore.
It's because you're looking at something cool at the Strip club.
Exactly.
There you go.
Nowhere you are.
Yeah.
You ate the edible.
Did Joey Diaz gave you that was mislabeled on purpose.
This is what you're seeing.
You're seeing something amazing and that amazing thing is making you want more
of it so you're.
You're spending more money to get a better computer to make better explosions on
the bigger screen that has the better sound and it keeps going deeper and deeper
and every fucking new phone has some new way to get you excited and you keep.
You're staring at the newest and best screen and it just locked into this sort
of hypnotic trance of technology.
Oh,
it allows.
It allows you to Bluetooth with your navigation so it syncs up to your car and
like you're still staring at a fucking screen and not doing anything.
It doesn't matter what's happening.
The same effect is taking place.
You're staring at a screen.
I've identified this sort of thing.
Um,
the,
an idea I've been working on called Yellowstone Syndrome though,
is where people,
Americans,
some,
so many of them,
their only idea about wildlife and wildlife politics and wildlife management
comes from the yellowstone story.
That they wind up having a difficult time understanding wildlife and wildlife
management in situations that are outside of a national park setting.
Which is to say they don't have a very good grasp on the inevitable conflicts
that are going to arise between wildlife and society and that's a large chunk of
ground where you just do not have those sorts of conflicts.
Like what kind of conflicts were talking about.
Oh,
like for instance,
a thing has been very difficult and very vexing for wildlife managers is what
happens to what happens to buffalo when they leave national.
The yellowstone national park.
I'm just,
I mean,
tobacco on the,
on the yellowstone is she goes to get a sense for how revolutionary that idea
was.
You know,
there was the Indian wars weren't even over when they made yellowstone.
Yellowstone,
you know,
we,
we were still battling American Indians on the great plains.
When you also want it to affect,
matter of fact,
yellowstone was a park when the Nez perce were chased through by the US army and
they actually killed a couple terrorists in yellowstone bright as some of the
buildings that are still there.
Wow.
Yeah.
So you were,
you went to yellowstone and got shot by Indians who were engaged in a war with
the US army.
Wow.
It was like a,
it was a,
it was like they hadn't even,
you know,
the West hadn't even been in some ways that the center west hadn't even been
settled and they were made and they made a national park and then Roosevelt went
there and uh,
you know,
at the commemoration to like,
it was,
you know,
went there to applaud it,
people look at me as if I still don't have my shit together,
but the only thing that I did was I took appeal that I thought was gonna give me
a boner.
And it literally,
it's caused me a lot of heartache and a lot of disappointment and a lot of it
just threw me
way,
shape or form.
When someone gives you this pill and you don't know where it came from,
you don't know.
What did you think,
man?
I don't know what's in this.
No,
I didn't.
I didn't think of it because,
um,
I had been dealing with the athletic commission.
I've been in the UFC for a long time and I've taken a little gas station,
take pills before,
like,
you know,
and I've never felt the drug test ever.
Did you ever think that you might have got lucky?
No,
I didn't think I got lucky.
I thought that you failed drug tests when you're doing sketchy shit.
Right?
But didn't you think there might be some sketchy shit and some Chinese?
No.
Station Rhino.
Dick pill?
I,
um,
what you know about the rhinos?
My friend Ryan,
my friend Brian called it,
he was on the,
on the podcast.
He said,
know John Likes to party.
I bet he took them
one of them Dick Pills.
Um,
no.
it's funny you called it.
Yeah,
well he was,
he was on
who's watching this video online yesterday of this girl who is a,
she's like a Vegan activist who had this video about why do we Turkey on
Thanksgiving.
It's a really well done video.
She's very,
it's very smartly edited and very smartly narrated and she starts talking about
the Turkey industry,
but she sets it up really well.
Like what did we just sort of do it,
like why do we turn and then she takes you to this Mike Rowe episode where they
show how they get Turkey come and that all these turkeys are so they're so
overbred and fucked up and they're so big so quick,
you literally can't physically have sex and they can watch on the catwalk.
And so these artificial insemination and so this guy has to literally talk,
talk sweet to them.
Yeah,
you gotta start sweet to them.
They have this Turkey's legs clamp down on this machine and then he's like
touching it and with a tube.
Uh,
and it's like holy because it has one hole and the sucking it in,
sucking it out with a straw.
Turkey's got to be like,
what the fuck going.
Exactly.
He's getting settled.
He's coming.
This guy has a tube.
He's sucking the come out of this Turkey's whole,
you know,
because they have like that one sort of universal whole for everything.
Yeah.
And as he sucking to out of it,
he has a glass,
a bottle of water with them because sometimes it gets in his mouth.
So he has to clean it out,
like kind of a fucking job,
but this is the only way you can get this stuff.
This dude Turkey rape should be illegal,
totally illegal.
But it's amazing that nobody talks about that.
But everybody talks about like force feeding ducks to get fog wall.